millions of people have been rethinking
their careers during this so-called
great resignation if you are one of them
researcher vanessa van edwards has some
tips for you she's the author of q's
master the secret language of
charismatic communication and she is
here with us now good morning good
morning thanks for having me so you say
vanessa that making a good first
impression begins with how you say hello
yes so most people don't realize
what you say is not important is how you
say it and the very first thing we're
doing in our first impression is we're
looking for confidence we like to be
around confident people we like to hire
confident people and this is a weird
measurement but the space between your
ear and your shoulder is the fastest way
we indicate confidence why when we're
nervous we bring our shoulders up we
tilt our chin down so i see people on
video they'll go hey
good morning or they hunt over their
computer or they start an interview and
they have their shoulders up the first
thing i want you to do is maximize this
distance it's a really weird measurement
but it actually signals confidence and
it also helps you speak more confidently
how you say hello can give away all your
vocals there's many ways to say hello
like what okay so here's what happens we
get nervous yeah we're hearing the phone
ring we're waiting for the video to pop
up we're walking in a room we hello
all the way up here all the way up into
our hob octave and we say hi at the top
of our breath the problem is that gives
away all your confidence what i want you
to do instead is say hello on the out
breath here listen to the difference
this is me top my anxiety hey nice to
see you
versus hey good to see you
so when you speak on the out breath it
forces your vocal cords to relax you
lower your shoulders and it signals such
nice confidence you know before you sat
down you said we're going to help people
get jobs today so people out there
saying thank you vanessa van edwards
we're going to help you but one of the
things you said was colors much to my
chagrin you said yellow which is my
favorite color by the way feel no
pressure you said yellow is not a good
color to wear on an interview why is it
why is it not and what is a good color
okay so with colors what you want to
think about is what it triggers for most
humans so yellow is a very bright color
it's high energy but it's your signature
color so here's a weird way to think
about colors you can create a signature
color or you can wear the color of the
brand so if you're interviewing a coke
wear red it looks like you fit in if
you're interviewing a pepsi wear blue
sprite wear green my favorite color
though is blue why this is my favorite
color today yeah tony got the job tired
i was so happy when i saw your suit
someone's wearing blue a pretty good
chance on a given day but isn't it a
little bit boring no no okay so blue so
blue what does it remind humans of clear
blue skies clear blue water it makes us
feel calm it makes us feel relaxed so
that's a great color to wear red now i
chose red today this is a high energy
color
intensity passion you only want to wear
red if you are bringing energy do not
let wear the red wear you right so today
i'm i'm trying to bring it so it's a
high energy color
black is actually the most boring color
no one's in black but i but i do wear
black outside of like my suits i'm
pretty much all in black all the time so
black is the most formal color and if
you have answers that can speak for
themselves you want to focus on your
content black is a great color to wear
because it can make you blend in your
answers can stand out the last color i
want you to consider is green green
human we think of spring we think of
fresh we think of new if you're looking
for money we think of money i mean
that's good too right i think a growth
in new beginnings growth in new
beginnings yes and so if you're looking
for a role with transition or change
green can be a very refreshing color to
wear so this is all good what to wear uh
how to say it but what to say words of
connection in virtual interviews what
are those so we've actually found we
wondered if you could make up for the
lack of a handshake in a virtual
interview could you actually say the
word that is that touchy-feely word and
what they found was is if you say oh i'm
sending a handshake from here or i'm
sending a virtual high five or it's so
good to see you saying those words
actually creates more of a physiological
response we actually measure that using
smartwatch technology and so saying
positive words especially not saying can
you see me
can you hear me yes i know oh the first
10 words you say in an interview can set
you up for success so think about those
first 10 words to make them slightly
positive so let me ask you when we were
talking backstage i had a mentor who
used to work at cbs news who constantly
told me to advocate for myself which i'm
not very good at doing believe it or not
and i know that there are people who go
into interviews and they say i'm the
next greatest thing you're hiring you've
got to hire me if you don't you're going
you're doing the wrong thing but i could
never do that but i said i'm off as
obnoxious and braggy okay so i want you
to advocate for yourself but not in
terms of labeling yourself so i don't
want you to say i'm successful i'm going
to be the next best thing for this role
i want you to do it with stories so
instead of saying you're successful or
productive say you know last my last
role i was able to create a system i was
productive and it was super successful
at that company so using stories to
advocate for yourself is a way of
talking about yourself that but also
feels comfortable not like you're
bragging it's such good advice your book
is so good vanessa because there is a
way you have to sell yourself but that
braggy word is never good and and soft
yes can i give one more kind of subtle
tip john tower says hurry up okay okay
mit found that if you subtly mirror your
interviewer you're going to earn 20 to
30 more in your salary so if they're
leaning forward you lean forward if
they're nodding i'm going to nod with
them
okay i had mirroring and marital
counseling didn't go so well this is a
job
about that it's a job interview okay
thanks vanessa van edwards always good
to see you we'll be right back